فأر هارب قطعة كبيرة من الجبن وعربة طعام
خارجة عن السيطرة تكاد
تكفي لإبعاد عقلك عن المساءلة
، كان الفأر في البيت الأبيض بيتر ألكساندر ، مراسل شبكة إن بي سي في البيت الأبيض ،
غرد
فأرًا سقط حرفياً من السقف
في كشكنا بالبيت الأبيض  هبطت
الصحافة في حضني ، وانتهى الأمر بمطاردة الطريق
في غرفة الإحاطة التي ألهمت
رسمًا كاريكاتوريًا على تويتر يُظهر قوارضًا محاصرًا
ونكات لا نهاية لها حول الفئران التي
تقفز حرفيًا على السفينة ، إنها
المخبرين الذي يفضل عدم
الكشف عن هويته ،
حاول شخص ما الإمساك به ووضع
شريط لاصق  الجانب اللاصق للأعلى ربما كان ينبغي
عليهم تجربة الجبن مثل قطعة
جبن البارميزان التي قدمها صحفي من برنامج
ساخر تحطمت فيه جلسة تصوير
بين وزيرة الخارجية بومبيو
ورئيس الوزراء الإيطالي ، حيث طلبت من بومبيو
تسليمها إلى الرئيس ترامب
قبل إبعادها.  كان الهدف من الحيلة
الاحتجاج على الرسوم الجمركية المحتملة على المنتجات الغذائية الإيطالية.
مطاردة في
البيت الأبيض ولكن الفأر لم يكن
الشيء الوحيد الذي يركض في هذه الدورة الإخبارية
مثل قارض يركض في دوائر مثل
عربة الطعام هذه في شيكاغو أوهير التي تدور
بعنف ، حيث انزلقت علبة ماء على
دواسة الوقود واصطدمت بالطائرة
هنا يذهب ولكن للإنقاذ
وصدم عضو فريق الخطوط الجوية الأمريكية
عربة بمركبة تستخدم لدفع الطائرات ، هذه هي
الطريقة التي يفعل بها هذا
المدرب المنحدر ، لكن شخصًا ما قام بتدوير عملية
الإنقاذ في ميم سياسي يصفه بأنه
خارج عن السيطرة  العربة هي إدارة ترامب
مع نانسي بيلوسي
والجمهوريين الذين يبحثون عن الازدهار الذي لا حول له ولا قوة ،
وهنا يأتي المخبر عن المخالفات وبهذه الطريقة
لا ترى أي شيء عن هذه
المخالفة جين موس سي إن إن نيويورك